I remember as a as a young
student you know trying to figure out
how did people get basically
um drawn in by Hitler how did that
happen and I'd watch newsreels and I'd
see this guy standing up there ranting
and raving and people shouting and
raising their arms I said what's
happened to these people why did they
believe that
I think it was difficult for
most Americans to believe that this guy
would be as dangerous as he turned out
to be and it's no longer just the whiff
of violence but the appeals to violence
look at immigration they don't want to
get together and try to resolve this uh
issue they don't want to try to figure
out how we have secure borders because
they'd rather have an issue than a
solution
this is an attack on freedom on
Democracy on Truth this is an attack
that has Ripple effects for all of us
the threats to democracy are real and
the only way to defeat them is showing
up and voting
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it is April 12th in the year 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals share subscribe tap the
notification Bell as always live post
game show you can correct me you can
question me you can poke and prod me at
reubenreport.locals.com the theme today
is that I've come to the conclusion
finally I've been Meandering around the
conclusion but I think we got to the
conclusion it's the Machine versus all
of us and you can either be in the
machine and I get why that's tempting
because it's a lot easier to be blue
pilled and be in the machine be a
non-playable character have no autonomy
over your life or you can be one of us
you can be one of the people that see
the world as it is and actually Fight
The Narrative that they are constantly
forcing down our throats I think it's a
little more challenging to live that way
but I sense it's probably a lot more
authentic a lot more real a lot better
as the kids say and I've had just about
enough of their dangerous propaganda and
nonsense so let's dive right into it I'm
going to start today with a video uh
from the BBC this is the British
Broadcasting Corporation and I just
finished watching the crown actually on
Netflix which was quite excellent if you
guys haven't been watching it and this
last season
they do quite a bit on the BBC uh but in
any event the BBC which is
state-sponsored Media
British Broadcasting Corporation right
so it is supposed to spin things a
certain way for the state sort of like
NPR gets money from the state etc etc
state-affiliated media now according to
Twitter uh in any event the uh CEO the
head man over at Twitter you might have
heard of this guy Elon Musk was
interviewed by a BBC reporter and they
got into a bit about hate speech and
this is so spectacular it is so
perfectly wonderful that I offer you
nothing more than to sit back and enjoy
as this poor schmuck gets destroyed
I understand what you mean by hateful
content and I'm asking for specific
examples
um and if and you just said that if
something is slightly sexist that's
hateful content does that mean that it
should be bad well you've asked me
you've asked me whether my feed whether
it's got less or more I'd say it's got
slightly more that's why I'm asking for
examples can I can you name one example
I I honestly don't need honestly I can't
name a single example I'll tell you why
because I don't actually use that for
you feed anymore because I just don't
particularly like it a lot of people a
lot of people are quite similar I I only
I only well you said you've seen more
hateful content but you can't name a
single example not even one I'm not sure
I've used that feed for the last
three or four weeks and then how did you
see the headboard contact because I've
been I've been using I've been using
Twitter since you've taken over for the
last six months okay so then you must
have at some point seen that you're for
you hateful content I'm asking for one
example right you can't give us
something and I'm saying I I say so that
you don't know what you're talking about
really yes because you can't be a single
example of hateful content not even one
tweet and yet you're claimed that the
hateful content was high well that's a
false no what I could just lied what no
no because people will say all sorts of
nonsense I'm literally asking for a
single example and you can't name one
right and as I already said I don't use
that feed but how would you know that I
don't think this is getting anything you
literally said you experienced more
hateful content and then couldn't name a
single example right and as I said
that's absurd I haven't I haven't
actually looked at that feed then how
would you know this beautiful content
because I'm saying that's what I saw a
few weeks ago I can't give you an exact
example I mean it just goes on and on
it's a little bit like who's on first
right like I experienced hate speech oh
can you give me an example I wasn't on
the thing well then how did you know
there was hate speech well I experienced
it well how did you know well I
experienced it how did you know you did
completely ridiculous I'm not even gonna
say the guy's name because he is getting
demolished across the interwebs at the
moment so there's no need to pile on him
specifically but but that moment I think
is so indicative of what we are seeing
across media right now whether it's the
internet or whether it's mainstream
media that there is this set of people
whether they work at the BBC or whether
they work at CNN MSNBC you know all The
Usual Suspects that they are in essence
paid operatives for the machine I don't
even think a lot of them know it like I
don't know anything about this guy I had
never heard of this guy before this I'm
going to go out on a limb and say he
doesn't know that he's sort of a paid
operative for the machine but he's just
he's just repeating the nonsensical
talking points of the machine that
suddenly there is more hate speech which
by the way the United States Supreme
Court as you guys know has ruled that
there is no such thing as hate speech
because one person's free speech is
another person's hate speech right there
are some limits around that related to
libel and slander which are very very
narrow and you can't point at somebody
and instigate a mob to go kill them that
sort of thing you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater with the intent to do
harm uh and a couple other things but
the point is that we have free speech
Elon Musk has respected it far more than
the previous regime at Twitter by the
way I'm not totally thrilled with
Twitter right now I still think it is
Extreme whacked and the numbers don't
really make sense and a lot of people
still tell me they don't see my stuff
and I think some degree of Shadow
Banning is still involved I don't blame
Elon Musk for that actually as he said
to me when I was there this thing is
like a fractal Rube Goldberg machine
remember a Rube Goldberg machine if you
don't know what they are they're awesome
Google it not while you're watching this
show but you know these machines you put
a ball in and then it jumps over this
thing and knocks over some dominoes and
then a water can fills up then it pours
on this and a spinning thing goes that
way and and he's saying it's a fractal
one of those like that's what the code
looks like it's just such a mess so I
think Twitter has all sorts of problems
but these people that just repeat the
nonsense somehow Twitter is meaner under
Elon Musk I'm getting way less hate
under Elon Musk somehow I don't know
what that is whether something was fixed
and they're not pushing people that hate
you to certain people but the point is
this guy doesn't even know what he's
talking about and look how quickly he
folds in the face of uh how about one
example right so this is this is like
what we've seen
many times over the years when Jordan
Peterson for example has gotten into it
with some mainstream media people that
they really don't know what they're
saying it's also partly why so many
Lefty Democrat politicians only go on
these Lefty shows why for example a guy
like me goes to DC we invite about 20
Democrats on and nobody showed up
because they know they'd get a little
pushback from me I'm not noted as the
most hardcore interviewer right but
they'd get a little pushback as opposed
to just being massaged having their
nonsense massaged all the way through
the factory but anyway let's continue on
this a little bit you guys know Matt
taibi Matt taibi is an actual journalist
I don't have to use air quotes he was
one of the original people he along
Barry Weiss were the first two uh to
release the Twitter files and I can tell
you
as forthright as I can possibly say
having been to Twitter myself if Matt's
experience at Twitter was anything like
mine which was literally just they
allowed me to sit around Engineers all
over the place Elon talking doors
opening closing people coming in and
then at the end me saying to him hey can
I write about this can I send out a
Twitter Thread about this and as you
know he said to me as long as it's true
so I'm going to suspect it was something
like that for Matt anyway Matt releases
the original Twitter files which were
all about government collusion on
Twitter stuff that we all suspected but
mainstream media would not and really
still has not covered because it would
actually Shine the Light on their
nonsense and and bs anyway he went on
MSNBC uh on the show this show by this
guy mehdi Hassan ahmedi who's an Al
Jazeera guy originally he has said some
really noxious things about gay people
over the years uh he's he's a far left
Progressive like he's standard it's
funny we don't show clips of this guy I
guess we're more of a joy read msnbc's
Joe Scarborough show for you anyway this
guy's just he's just like sort of just
like a terrible Lefty propagandist again
from Al Jazeera so you can sort of put
that together uh anyway here he is Matt
taibian his show related to Elon Musk
and the Twitter files and just watch
this
so when you criticize him today for
Banning journalists for working with
Modi government to shut down speech for
you know being anti-union you can go for
I'll give you as much time as you like
would you like to criticize much now no
I don't I don't particularly want to
um look I didn't I didn't criticize them
really before
uh and I think that what the Twitter
files are uh is a step in the right
direction
um but it's the same Twitter that he's
running right now just agree with him if
you want to ask I think well I'll ask
you a specific one
no no no no no what's in bad faith Matt
sorry you say that Twitter hold on hold
on let me finish my question you're
saying that he's good for Twitter and
good for speech I'm saying he's using
Twitter to help one of the most
right-wing governments in the world
center speech I will criticize that will
you
I have to do I have to look at the story
first I'm not looking at it now hold on
hold on I I posted the story two weeks
ago you tweeted at me like I don't watch
the midi Hassan show
I don't watch the many Assad show I mean
it's just perfect nobody does like trust
me we have way more viewers on a daily
basis with than this guy it doesn't even
matter but anyway the point of this is
when I talk about how they launder the
lies right so the media completely
buried the hunter Biden story for all
the time that a whole bunch of us were
saying they were Shadow Banning you know
if you'd say this about the lab leak or
this about the vaccines or mandates but
we're getting suspended and banned the
media didn't care about that then taibi
releases he's one of the people that
releases these Twitter files Hassan has
no interest in that he has no interest
in the fact that the government has been
exposed to be colluding to silence Free
Speech a direct violation of the First
Amendment he's not interested in that
he's just trying to get Matt taibi on
whether Matt tybe is upset that Elon
Musk doesn't like unions like it's it's
just completely irrelevant Elon Musk is
allowed to have his own feelings on uh
unions he's also allowed to have his own
feelings on literally anything because
he's a free citizen of the free at least
for now United States of America anyway
here's just a tiny bit more and this is
like a full wrecking of this Hassan
fella and and I don't think we're going
to need to talk about this guy anymore
after today so we'll go back to our
regularly scheduled
Joy Reed Joe Scarborough nonsense here
you go
outline and muscles those are your words
the hilarity of this coming from MSNBC
which did nothing but vomit up uh fake
Russian stories that came straight from
the FBI for six consecutive years now
you guys still haven't apologized for uh
right there in that period so I've got
nothing to apologize I'm asking you
you're
leaving there Matt thank you for
appearing on the show we'll appreciate
it
appreciate it I don't think I've ever
written about the hunter Biden story so
maybe you should apologize for putting
words in my mouth you said at the
beginning I put words I never said a
word about the Honda Biden
[Music]
do do
you see why they want to censor people
so when the internet meme makers put
together something like that I've never
said a word about the hunter Biden
laptop story and then the people of the
internet the good humans out there and
there's plenty of them they're like oh
let me just go on Twitter and see if I
put medie's name in alongside uh if I
put Betty's name alongside Hunter Biden
laptop I've never said anything and look
how quickly they can expose the nonsense
so do you see why they want so many of
us censored they want us censored and
it's not just it's not just guys like
taibi or guys like me it's people like
you they want us all censored so we'll
all just swallow The Narrative and they
use hate speech to mask the true intent
the true intent is full censorship and
controlling the narrative here is a
beautiful video by my friend David sax
who's been on the show many times
investor and from the all-in podcast who
I think has become a really great clear
voice of what's going on in this country
politically these days talking about how
these establishment uses hate speech as
a red herring as a as a complete
fabrication so that they can push their
own agenda
um I you know I tend to think that that
this whole idea of hate speech is a
little bit of a red herring I think it's
what the left wants you to believe that
the debate about free speech is about so
this is where I I would disagree with
Glenn a little bit um is that um
is that I think that within First
Amendment case law you have this really
uh thorny fraud area of hate speech
which is generally allowed under the
First Amendment but it's something that
no one really wants on social networks
they don't want it next to them they
don't want to participate with that and
what the left has wanted to do ever
since Elon took over
um Twitter is to say that this is all
about allowing more hate on the platform
and that's never been the motivation I
think for those of us who really care
about Free Speech right even this is
true I think for Glenn what what is our
main concern about censorship it is
political suppression it's about
narrative control it's not like we want
more hate on the platform it's just that
we want
we want a Level Playing Field we don't
want uh the you know thought police at
Twitter putting their thumb on the scale
of American democracy and deciding who
has a voice and who doesn't that's what
this is really about and
um and I think that the people who
believe in censorship want to make you
think that this is about allowing more
hate and it's not
you know it's so interesting because
David's making a couple of great points
there but even if there was more
quote-unquote hate on Twitter right now
or across the internet right now
um would that be a reason to stifle
political dissent would that be a reason
to stop someone else's free speech I
don't think so you know there were years
and years when I was still at my leaving
the left phase the amount of hate that I
was getting online I mean thousands of
tweets every day dozens of emails
Facebook everything it was pretty awful
at the beginning of all this now I think
mostly they these people have largely
given up on me as a Target because I
survived because I walked right through
the fire and if you do that
and you don't let them destroy you
eventually they they find new enemies to
find because they're like oh man in some
ways I actually thank the people that
were my haters for all this time because
they made me stronger it actually
doubled me down on doing the right thing
uh but but just because there
potentially would be more hate which
there's no evidence of right which is
why the BBC reporter didn't know what he
was talking about there's no evidence of
it you'd be able to show it very easily
in a chart well here were you know but
they can't they can't they make this
stuff up 100 completely
um the other thing that uh Sachs is
hitting on there is that it's
interesting also because when Elon took
over Twitter suddenly everyone started
talking about hate speech right they
weren't really talking about hate speech
on Twitter before every now and again if
a bunch of right-wingers went after you
know some like a black actress or
something they'd say Twitter's full of
hate but then suddenly when Elon got it
was all about hate and then there were
suddenly all these articles about
Twitter's doing nothing about its child
porn problem
and it's interesting because they didn't
care about Twitter's child porn problem
before Elon got it but then they saw it
as a way of getting Elon Elon has now
done more about child porn on Twitter
than the entire regime did for the 15
years of Twitter's existence before Elon
so they didn't even care about it and
there was somebody that did a great
study on this where they found all of
the Articles mainstream media articles
about Twitter and child porn post Elon
getting Twitter and none literally not
one of the writers who had wrote those
articles since Elon got Twitter had ever
written about child porn problems on
Twitter before Elon got it so you can
see the narrative so what what is this
really all about well the when you
control the narrative it makes us care
and focus on things that we don't care
about and that we don't want our lives
in our lives one of those things would
be woke beer so you know the big story
over the last week or so has been that
Bud Light which is obviously from
Anheuser-Busch the Clydesdales all that
stuff uh Bud Light uh went woke they
decided to make Dylan Mulvaney who is a
biological man who has quote unquote
transitioned and lives Life as a female
it is unclear what genitals he or she
has I'm not going to make anyone in this
room Google it today because I'm just
feeling that I shouldn't for one day can
we take one day off Googling people's
genitals here at the Reuben report but
the company has lost about four billion
dollars since this has happened because
people have had it with this nonsense
the average person who drinks Bud Light
is not interested in a guy pretending to
be a girl
promoting their beer right a guy that
Bud Light was always marketed to guys
drinking at the football game and blah
blah blah anyway how does this happen
how does this happen well sometimes you
can find out in a very direct way here
is video of Alyssa heinershide she's Bud
light's VP of marketing so she is the
one that put Dylan Mulvaney in this
marketing piece okay this was all her uh
her idea and listen as she talks about
her inclusive strategy here and then
wonder if this is the type of woman
you'd want working at your company
I'm a businesswoman I had a really clear
job to do when I took over Bud Light and
it was this brand is in Decline it's
been in Decline for a really long time
and if we do not attract
young drinkers to come and drink this
brand there will be no future for Bud
Light so I had this super clear mandate
it's like we need to evolve and Elevate
this incredibly iconic brand and my what
I brought to that was a belief in okay
what is what what does evolve and
elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone it means having
a campaign that's truly inclusive and
feels lighter and brighter and different
and appeals to women and to men and
representation is it sort of the heart
of evolution you've got to see people
who reflect you in the work and we had
this hangover I mean Bud Light had been
kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
I mean this woman
who I assume soon will be fired by
Anheuser-Busch if you own a company and
you're looking for someone in marketing
you stay as far away as this from this
person as you can and this is exactly
why diversity equity and inclusion ruin
everything she was embarrassed basically
is what she's saying in the last line
there the fratty low brow humor of what
Bud Light Came to represent those are
the people who liked that beer it's not
the most high-end beer it was beer that
you drink with your buddies or at a frat
party or out of a keg upside down or out
of a funnel or what else are people
doing with Bud Light beer cracking it
over their heads and whatever uh it
wasn't for now she wants to make it it's
for men and for women although Dylan
Mulvaney's a little of both I guess and
this thing that she wanted to make it
inclusive that beer should be inclusive
Connor you're the beer guy here when you
go to the store and you're selecting you
got all the beers there are you looking
for inclusivity in your beer are you
looking for a gay flag maybe some sort
of black power fist in your beer how do
you decide your beer choice
what's that
you want a beer with pronouns you want a
beer you're going you're going for
alcohol content you're going for whether
you're like an IPA or something like
like it's just nonsense but again these
people get into these companies and
she's basically saying it my job wasn't
to strengthen that iconic brand you know
figure out well where are the there are
still new frat guys out there there are
new people that have kind of worked with
this if if she felt it was kind of Aging
out or it didn't feel as cool as it used
to there's ways to do that but then to
to she's embarrassed this is what it is
she's embarrassed by the people that
bought her product the product she was
uh hired to sell and that is a major
freaking problem uh we have a little
more from her I think we have a little
more from her yeah uh oh no not from her
this is this is wild so check this out
so they've lost about four billion
dollars this is video that a guy who is
an Anheuser-Busch affiliate so he's one
of the guys that brings the the beer you
know because they don't have
Anheuser-Busch plants everywhere so they
have these Affiliates that bring the
beer to the stores all over the country
and here's a guy doing a selfie video
talking about how the the lack of sales
now because of this Dylan Mulvaney trans
nonsense inclusivity in light beer uh
what it's doing to his business
um I work for an affiliate company
I am a merchandiser
and the sole product of the company I
work for is anheuser-brush products
so with all this canceling going on
um
there's I mean I've never seen such
little sales in this past few days on
these products it's it's sad because
people don't buy this beer
I don't make money
and I can't feed my family
so it's kind of uh
heartbreaking I guess that
um
Anheuser-Busch did what they did
they don't know their clientele
so it's uh kind of heartbreaking
thanks Anheuser-Busch I may not be able
to feed my family coming up here soon
so obviously the the may not be able to
feed my family that's the that's the
banner one on that and hopefully he'll
find another job with a better
distributor but again this goes to the
point they don't know their audience or
they're ashamed of Their audience
because these wokesters don't want white
Frat Boys drinking their beer and call
me crazy but if I was in charge of a
beer company I wouldn't care who's
drinking the beer if I saw a lot of beer
being sold and drank all over the
country I wouldn't be going well how
many white people are drinking our beer
how many Lesbos are drinking our beer
how many uh trans people and how many
gays like it's so nonsensical but that
is why the woke mind virus infects and
destroys the host almost without
exception so now I want to connect this
a little bit to what's going on
politically right now so you remember a
couple weeks ago there was this horrific
shooting at the Christian School six
people killed three students and I think
three faculty members
um it was absolutely awful uh well then
there was some protests there were
protests against guns of course right
the Democrats then protest against guns
even though it was good guys with guns
that stopped the shooter who was trans a
radical trans activist or at least
identified as trans it's hard to even
know just because someone says they're
trans doesn't actually mean anything
anymore but as you probably heard over
the last couple days there have been a
bunch of protests at the Tennessee
Capitol you might say insurrections
because a bunch of people who are not
invited in got in there wouldn't leave
blah blah blah and then two
representatives were kicked out so
here's here's a little info from 19th
news in Tennessee members of the
republican-dominated State House will
vote today on whether three lawmakers
Gloria Johnson Justin Pearson and Justin
Jones should be removed from their seats
for engaging in Acts of protests over
gun violence okay so that was a couple
days ago subsequently what happened now
they came in they were using bull horns
they were not allowed allowed to two of
them were actually expelled I've got a
little info from the daily wire this is
this morning the votes on expulsion
followed the filing of resolutions on
Monday against Jones Gloria Johnson and
Pearson a vote to expel Johnson failed
by one vote representative Gina bolso
who's a republican said that the
Democrats had tried to shred the state's
Constitution with the bullhorn during
the debate on these resolutions Johnson
suggested the reason she was not
expelled might have been racially
motivated during his defense Pearson
also attempted to make the debate about
race suggesting the Tennessee
Republicans were racist and invoking
black women who stood at the cross when
Jesus was crucified Gloria Johnson was
the one out of the three that was not
revoked now she happens to be a white
woman the two that were were black men I
cannot mind read as to why the
legislature the Republicans decided to
do that are they so outwardly racist or
was something else going on there all
three of them
as far as I can tell broke the the laws
that they are supposed to abide by you
can't bring a bullhorn into the house
they have certain laws of decorum as
every state house has as our Capital has
uh etc etc they brought protesters in
which they weren't supposed to like
there's there's a series of things there
maybe she wasn't directing all of it I
suspect we'll find out a little bit more
about that now I want to show you video
of one of the guys who has since
suspended his name is Justin Pearson
at the Capitol this is a day or two ago
take a look
[Music]
I don't know how long this Saturday in
the state of Tennessee might last but oh
we have good news folks we've got good
news that Sunday always comes well
that's that's pretty powerful he's got
the hair and the thin tie and he's got
the MLK accent that's powerful stuff
that feels very authentic doesn't it
hot damn here he is same guy 2016.
Justin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I want to do this by
partnering with organizations from the
booty Democrats to the Boon Republicans
I want to bring together different
voices dissenting voices voices that may
be more liberal or more conservative in
order that we can reach a point of sort
of the radical middle
thank you
that was him as a normal person speaking
in normal Cadence back in 2016. let's
just watch five or ten more seconds of
him just a couple days ago
seem like the NRA and gun lobbyists
might win
but all that was good news for us I
don't know how long this Saturday in the
state of Tennessee might last you know
I'm starting to think that anyone can do
an accent like that and I don't know how
long I can do the accent for but I'll do
it as long as I have to to drive home
the point that anyone can talk in a
certain way and I can lift a coffee mug
and talk over here even though I'm
talking to nobody and I can take out my
ChapStick and I can put it on and tell
everybody from sea to shine and see that
if you just use this accent then gosh
darn it you're making a better point
because if you talk like this and I want
to bring the Democrats and the
Republicans together that doesn't really
work you understand you've got to grow
out the hair you've got to tell the
people what your problem is and you've
got to get the media to tell everybody
that your MLK too because this kid over
here he was just saying hey Republicans
and Democrats maybe we can find some
things together but it doesn't work to
do with that away
Kamala Harris who is the vice president
or acting as the vice president whatever
she's doing she went to Nashville we
have a tweet here about her visit uh
Kamala visited Nashville to meet three
expelled lawmakers but not the attack
victims Biden invited the lawmakers to
the White House but not the cops who
stopped the shooter are you paying
attention yet so really think about
what's going on here
she went to Tennessee she did not meet
with the families of the victims there
are three families of children whose
children are dead
Kamala Harris did not go meet with them
she met with those lawmakers she did not
go meet with the families of the
teachers that are dead and here is video
of her defending the storming of the
Tennessee Capitol again breaking the
laws of the Tennessee Capitol we're told
these things are insurrections but as
you guys know Democrat privilege when
you're a Democrat you can get away with
it
they chose to lead and show courage to
say
that a democracy
allows
for places where the people's voice will
be heard
and honored and respected
and they understood the importance these
three
of standing
to say that people will not be silenced
to say that a democracy hears the cries
here's the please who here is the
demands
of its people who say the children
should be able to live and be safe and
go to school and not be in fear
isn't it incredible the way I talk when
I'm trying to make a point and I'm
whispering sort of like Joe Biden and
I'm not really telling you exactly what
happened and I could have gone one mile
over to visit the families of the dead
children but I'm more concerned with the
Trans Community even though it was a
trans shooter and I'm also more
concerned to make this about politics so
I can take people's guns Ukraine big
Russia small
absolutely ridiculous uh but who do they
blame oh this is a good one here's a
doozy for you uh here is cringe
Jean-Pierre White House Press Secretary
uh and she's very upset with Ron
DeSantis over this trans shooter killing
six people in Tennessee
now you might be going but wait a minute
Rhonda said this is the governor of
Florida well there's a couple things
going on here they obviously fear Ron
DeSantis more than anyone else at the
national level and as a matter of fact
here in Florida just this past week we
did pass we have a super majority a
republican super majority here and we
passed uh constitutional carry meaning
you don't have to have an extra permit
to carry your gun you got your gun
legally you did your background checks
and everything else which Gavin Newsom
of course was lying about yesterday we
covered that you don't need an extra
permit you already got your permit to
have your gun and that's what we're
doing here in Florida we have states
rights that's how it is but cringe on
Pierre basically blaming the Texas
shooting on Ron DeSantis
a concealed permitless concealed weapon
law I Know You released a statement but
does the White House feel that when laws
like this are passed in States like
Florida that it undermines the work is
doing to address the uh the nation's gun
epidemic so we think it's shameful it's
certainly shameful and tragic especially
after a school shooting
it's shameful and tragic it's shameful
and tragic that a state
uses its state authority to do what it
wants to do in its state not breaking
any laws doing what the people voted for
because we voted for the super majority
here we voted in a landslide for the
governor the people just one more time
guys because the Democrats in the media
lie about this relentlessly
this is about the permit you don't need
a second permit to conceal carry because
if you have your gun legally if you have
your gun illegally you're in trouble
already right but if you have your gun
legally you've had your background
checks you got your permit they did
whatever they needed to do and each
state decides what that is and then you
are allowed to carry your gun but it's
shameful after a shooting you know it
was it was good guys with guns that
stopped that shooting it's funny I don't
know that she said anything about how
it's shameful that so many people like
her in her mainstream media cohorts have
have radicalized the far left
Progressive trans whatever base to the
point that we've had a couple trans
shooters or trans identifying Shooters
as of late but this all goes to show
that the the culture and the narrative
at the top level at the federal level at
the mainstream media level it's all Bs
and nonsense but there are good things
happening bottom up whether it is online
shows where you can get a degree of
Truth or the states which are doing the
work they are supposed to be doing
protecting the rights of their citizens
that's exactly what's happening here in
Florida although that's a far cry from
what's Happening uh in Illinois as you
know Chicago Illinois gave the boot to
Lori Lightfoot that's right Lori
Lightfoot is no more although I'm told
if you say her name three times she will
come back from the dead and scare the
hell out of the kids they did the
however elect another far left whack job
Progressive so what's going to happen
more good people the good decent
citizens who remain in Chicago they will
flee they will come to places like
Florida DeSantis was talking about that
yesterday
follow some of the the elections outside
of Florida because it affects Florida
this Chicago mayor people are going to
flee Chicago in even greater numbers we
are going to get more refugees as a
result of that because it's like you
know you see what's not working and you
go even further in that direction you
know you just wonder like what is going
on but there's no question that I think
you're going to continue to see downward
there and I think you're going to see
people we've already had we've had
massive businesses move out of there
into Florida into Texas some other
places but I think you're going to see
probably more residents would be would
be my guess and uh you know so so we
monitor see just because you see the you
see the result I mean that's that's uh
that will be very imperative guys I want
to be just crystal clear on one point
here I am completely okay with this at
this point it is just fine with me if
the red States get redder and the blue
States get Bluer and you have to make a
decision it's up to you and we all have
family pressures job pressures
elderly parents children in school all
of the stuff that you I can't move for
this reason or I should move for this
reason or I'm financially tied to this
or I grew up here all of those things
but at the end of the day these things
are splitting they are splitting whether
you like it or not and again our
Founders were so ingenious they were so
brilliant that they set up this system
that you would have a place to flee
because the experiment would allow for
these Laboratories of democracy to all
do it a little bit differently and you
could find a place that was in line with
your views and maybe it's not the place
you grew up in maybe it's not the place
you intended to live but it but that but
it is up to you that is the beauty so
you might be going well David this new
Chicago mayor can't be worse than Lori
Lightfoot Lori Lightfoot one of the
worst public servants just one of the
most vile disgusting people that we've
had in politics I mean remember that
moment during covid where first off she
was outside without a mask for the BLM
riots she said well sometimes things go
beyond public Health but then she was
you know that speech we've shown it to
you a million times where she was
talking about we will find you and we
will arrest you disgusting little
creature anyway yes they've gone even
further left than her the new mayor of
Chicago is a guy by the name of Brandon
Johnson uh he used to be a teacher uh
here were some of his policies while he
was teaching
it taught me though was
pushing like to eliminate sort of the
standardization of our Public Schools my
students sometimes would get frustrated
I didn't offer any test prep many of my
other colleagues were doing it at the
time I was pushing our Administration to
move away from that
to be quite Frank with you I didn't
issue a lot of homework for students
that was my own way of sort of rebelling
against the structure
um I I don't think I ever gave a kid an
F
I just I don't I don't know how a
student sits in front of you and fail I
mean there's so much there so no test
prep
guys there's a test tomorrow I can't
tell you anything about it I have no
freaking clue what's going to be on that
thing good luck with all of that that's
one thing he didn't do much homework in
his defense I always felt there was too
much homework in high school I guess
that one's a little debatable I'm trying
to be fair here and he didn't give
anyone an F
these people they there is no bottom to
this hold do you guys get that like what
he's saying there is I wouldn't want a
kid to think that he's an idiot but some
kids are idiots and you know what you do
you give them an f and then you know
what happens they then might go you know
I don't like being left back a year or I
don't like being made fun of by my
friends or I don't like being dumb and
then they might start working harder
I'll tell you something I've never said
publicly before you want one never said
publicly this happened to me I was in
the uh what year was this ninth grade so
this is uh about 1990 91 something like
that in math I I was never paying
attention in math my teacher was very
funny this guy was Mr Mr T we called him
I had a long last name like an Armenian
last name we called him Mr T this guy
was funny as hell and he didn't really
teach that much math but he was funny I
loved that class but I had no idea what
was going on but somehow like I was
always kind of bright enough that I
could like sort of fake it throughout
the year but then in New York we had
something called the Regents and that
was this the standardized test by the
state at the end of the year and you had
to pass the Regents to then get into
10th grade math and at 10th grade math
you had to pass the regions against
I failed the regions and then you know
what happened I got stuck when I was in
10th Grade back with the ninth graders
for a semester
and I was with the morons and the Freaks
and the idiots and then I was like well
I really screwed up here and I got a
tutor and I studied real hard and I got
out of it in half the semester roughly I
think I got out a little bit early so it
was like half a semester or something
and then I went on and did just fine in
math for the rest I never really loved
it but I did it just fine
felt good to tell people that you know
got it off my chest so there I am I took
the Regents in ninth grade twice okay
there you go so you might go to this guy
all right all right
you just want to tell the kids what's on
the test he doesn't want to give them
much homework he doesn't want to give
apps now he's the mayor like how could
that translate how could this sort of
equity in education translate into
policy well he's also not really into
policing he's sort of down with Riot and
looting things of that nature here he is
in 2020.
there was rioting and organized looting
last night and you're calling to defund
the police explain that
yeah what we're seeing is obviously is
uh an outbreak of incredible frustration
um and anguish that communities that
have been isolated
um through poverty over generations and
what we have is
um sort of a typical very standard quite
frankly a very tired response
um to the regularly scheduled pandemic
which is structural racism and that
response has been to increase
um police presence that has not led to
anything of substance to secure
communities and to make communities
whole
such nonsense do you know study after
study has proven that when you send more
policing into these areas these high
crime areas that crime goes down and
when you take policing out and you
defund the police people then are upset
because next thing you know oh grandma
got shot
could somebody oh there's nobody around
because we defunded the police
we know this over and over we know what
happened it's not just in Chicago I mean
the best example is what happened in
Minneapolis because ilhan Omar was the
number one Pusher of defund the police
Minneapolis became an absolute
crime-infested dump murders theft
larceny all of it went skyrocketing then
she started blaming the police officers
for not doing their jobs after she
basically handcuffed them and and
defunded them and then you wonder why as
the Santa said we take the refugees here
in Florida and of course the question
always remains will the refugees vote
the right way I think so far for the
most part people are getting it so the
question remains however how do voters
feel that Trump Biden DeSantis whoever
else how do they all fit into this
cultural mix this this Narrative of good
guy bad guy defund the police fund the
police blue red blah blah blah how does
it all happen well or how do they all
fit into that puzzle well first off uh
you may have seen this over the weekend
uh Easter I mentioned this yesterday uh
but Joe Biden was asked by Al Roker of
NBC he was asked whether he's going to
run for president again and and really
try to count the errors in this sentence
try to count the consecutive words that
make sense the flummoxing and everything
else I mean it's as big of a softball
question are you gonna run for president
like have something ready to roll just
listen to this and also just watch watch
Jill Dr Jill Biden as she's she's next
to him just praying that each word can
get out of his mouth
so that's a fantastic event one of my
favorites of the year I was just
wondering uh Mr President will you be
taking part in the Easter egg rolls
after planning on after 2024. I plan on
at least three or four more Easter egg
rolls at least three or four maybe five
maybe five maybe six what the hell are
you are you saying that uh that you
would be uh taking part in uh our
upcoming election in 2014. I'll either
be rolling an egg or you know being the
the you know the guy who's pushed him
out come on help a brother out
I plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet all right
well I think it's so nice and thank you
for having us up here good to be here
thank you
you see the way Dr Jill looks at him at
that moment where he's clearly flummoxed
he doesn't know what he's going to say
and then he says I'll either be the guy
who's rolling the egg or who's pushing
them out
does he think he's a rabbit he thinks
he's an actual Easter bunny rabbit
pushing out an egg it is just wild
anyway it looks like he's gonna run but
as I've been saying they are absolutely
prepping Gavin Newsom in case of the
brain hemorrhage or whatever might you
know the fall up the stairs whatever
might happen to Joe Biden but now I want
to transition a little bit into the
other side of the aisle for a moment
because uh president Trump was on Tucker
Carlson's show last night for rather
extensive interview I got a couple Clips
here uh and as you guys know I've been
somewhat hard on Trump lately because I
think of because of some of the behavior
not the policies I think some of the
attacks have not been warranted and I
think it's turning off a lot of people
but I'll always give credit where credit
is due and again I do for the most part
like Trump voted for him etc etc uh
here's Trump talking about whether he
thinks Biden will even run in 2024.
do you think Biden will stay in the race
look uh
I I watch him just like you do
and I think it's
almost inappropriate for me to say it I
don't see how it's possible but there's
something wrong
I saw his answer today
on television about whether or not he
was going to run to a very nice guy
named Al Roker
when you can't get us off to a question
then that that was a long answer
talking about the eggs and this and that
look
I don't think he can
I don't think he can it's kind of right
right like so that's sort of trump at
his best when he's just saying what he
thinks and usually what he thinks is
what most of us are thinking but
probably not saying now I have no
problem saying this stuff about Biden
it's become incredibly obvious but you
know the mainstream media the corporate
press refuses to say it they will run
out of their way to say that Biden is
completely fine Jill Biden who is who is
the real criminal in all of this just a
couple weeks ago saying we would never
consider taking a cognitive test for Joe
Biden I mean that's actually crazy
that's actually evil if you are married
to this man and supposedly love this man
and we all know something's wrong but
the Democrats are going all in on this I
think because he is just the vessel and
whether the driver of the vessel is
Obama or whatever that is behind it he
is the perfect Patsy to just get up
there and as always poorly read the
nonsensical statements that are ushering
in all this communism and Wrecking our
economy and all of these things Tucker
then went on to ask Trump about his
future because obviously there's the
indictment in New York there's this
potential indictment coming down the
pike in Georgia which everyone really is
saying I mean people that I trust about
legal issues are saying has far more
teeth than the New York one so Tucker
asked Trump if he would ever consider
dropping out
is there anything they could throw at
you legally that would convince you to
drop out of the race if you get
convicted in this case in New York no
I'd never dropped something I think I
wouldn't do it
I believe him I believe him I believe he
will run right through this I believe he
will walk into the fire and do this to
the extent that he can if it gets to a
point where he's losing a whole bunch of
primaries and it's just not looking good
then he would get out I would say the
other reason he could potentially get
out is he is of a certain age and
anything can happen to anybody
regardless of their age but you know if
he suddenly had a back problem or
couldn't be on stage or whatever else it
might be like that could pull him out
but I don't think that the indictment
maybe what what Alvin Bragg and the
Soros people and and the entire Democrat
establishment we're all hoping was they
could scare the hell out of him with
this indictment and that subtly he would
be like you know if I now I see that
they've really creeped onto me here like
this is different than them just saying
mean things like this is like serious
stuff now this is their way of making me
back off maybe I'll take the bait he did
not take the bait and now I believe he
will be all in uh Trump also started
talking about who America's biggest
enemy is and I thought his answer here
uh was actually quite good
who's the biggest problem sir is it
China could it be Russia could it be
North Korea no I said the biggest
problem is from within
it's these sick radical people
from within because we can handle if
we're smart we can handle Russia China
I did it was a sad day in many ways
there are many days ways it was a
beautiful day because the people
understand I didn't know this was
happening but the poll numbers have gone
through the roof
the people get it and the other ones are
hoaxes also you know the Box hoax okay
Biden he's got 1850 boxes and you know
that's a hoax and then the one in
Atlanta where I had a perfect phone call
this is all weaponization they're
weaponizing our justice system Tucker
and they think if they go and give you a
subpoena you know I guess I'm very well
known and people understand it and they
get it and maybe I have a bigger
platform so I can explain it but if
you're somebody of Republican let's say
running for office and you get a
subpoena
you might as well resign because you're
not going to be able to survive it and
you the voters aren't going to handle it
the voters aren't going to take it what
they're doing is weaponizing the system
and there's never been anything like it
okay so look this is this is Trump when
he is clear and cogent and saying
something that is deeply true the system
has been weaponized against him because
he is an enemy of the system he's not
running around saying we must stop China
we must stop Russia actually what he's
saying is we didn't have a lot of
problems with Russia and China when I
was President which actually was true
and every time he said something you
know sort of quote unquote anti-china
they would call him a racist right but
Russia did not invade Ukraine under him
they did under Obama and they did
underbite and so you know you got it the
proof's in the pudding on this some of
this stuff so this is Trump's this is
Trump at his best right I think part of
the issue though he is going to have
around this is that the more he gets
bogged down in these indictments and
having to worry about this stuff who
will see does it affect the campaigning
does it affect his overall energy you
know a lot of people have been saying to
me his energy seemed off because the
first time around there was so much
excitement around it and it was this
make America great again thing and it
all felt new and the trolling and
everything else I just don't think he
can replicate that again and he's gonna
have to figure out what that means uh
but as you know my frustration has been
about the attacks the crazy attacks but
I want to show you one more
clip of trump on Tucker last night
because uh Gavin Newsom came up because
Gavin Newsom has been doing this tour of
America and he's clearly like do not
have any question in your mind about
this he's clearly doing this because
they are prepping him in case Biden
falters and I don't know how they're
going to do it I don't know how it could
even be done legally but they will
figure out a way to push Kamala Harris
to the side it will be the diverse and
inclusive Democrats who push the black
woman out of the side for the
cisgendered white Christian male and
they'll gladly do it with a smile on
their face that devil worshiping freak
anyway uh Trump was asked by Tucker
about his relationship with Newsome and
this is really really fascinating
I used to get along great with him you
know when I was President I had a lot
you know got along really good Gavin
well you got along with Gavin news I did
I really did he was always very nice to
me said the greatest things he would say
things like he's doing a great job oh he
was very about you help me that's why I
could never hit him because he was so
nice to me
that's a really bad line guys that's a
really bad line and it goes to what
everyone's concerns are about Trump at
this point he was always nice to me he
said nice things about me and that's why
I couldn't hit him
this is the guy who's telling everyone
he's going to drain the swamp so now
imagine it's it's uh 2025 right Trump
sworn in he's president he gets back to
D.C and he's about to drain the swamp
and he walks into the FBI and the head
of the FBI is like President Trump your
hair looks great today it's a little
extra fluffy looks really great he'll be
like what I was going to drain the swamp
oh thanks I'm not going to hit you too
hard like that actually is his weakness
this this need to be liked by people who
do not like him or whose actions are in
complete polar opposite to everything he
purports to believe in this is what he
seemingly does all the time he'll tell
you that the New York Times is failing
all the time which actually is true and
that it's not a place of actual
journalism but then he'll constantly do
interviews with Maggie Haberman who then
throws him under the bus and then he
fights with her so he keeps doing this
but this is I think this is a real
Achilles heel that's a really bad line I
couldn't hit him because he was nice to
me and that's the guy who is supposedly
the savior of the Republic like that's
weak man but now I want to show you this
this is a compilation of trump praising
Newsome during covid
putting that to the backdrop of what he
just said is this not interesting right
so he just said I couldn't criticize him
because he was nice to me now we know
that California was perhaps the worst
Michigan might have been worse maybe New
York but like California top three for
sure in worse States related to coveted
most Draconian lockdowns the most amount
of people leaving all of the stuff you
guys get all of it but now watch this
compilation having just heard that he
said he couldn't hit Newsom because
Newsom was nice to him
you look at what's going on in
California where they're doing a
fantastic job they really are the
governor's doing great
I'm proud of them I've gotten very
friendly with Gavin Newsom he's done a
very good job here I watched
what's been happening in California with
Governor Newsom and this morning with
Governor Cuomo and I applaud them
they're taking very strong bold steps
and I applaud them we agree on the
coronavirus and on that we've got along
very well and our relationship began
earlier than most and so from that
perspective all I can say is from my
perspective the relationship has been
strong it's going to really a terrific
job in California well we've gotten
along very well Gavin Newsom we've got
very well with regard to uh covid-19 as
we call it in that respect he's been
fantastic and we've been fantastic and
he said very generous things yeah
California by the way also doing a very
good job Governor Newsom yeah I'm going
to meet with the governor right now
Gavin Newsom we've worked very well
together
okay I am not trying to be
um sort of unnecessarily critical of
trump here but I think what we just did
there shows you a little something Trump
can be wooed very easily if you are just
nice to him he will run around and say
you're doing a great job with covet as
California was locking their citizens in
their homes and Gavin Newsom was eating
at French Laundry and they were kicking
people out of school and all of those
things
somehow Gavin Newsom became one of his
good friends during all of this that is
just something for those of you that
watch this show that are hardcore Trump
people and again I voted for the guy in
like the guy and I hope I'll sit down
with him over the next couple of months
you have to think about that like are we
allowed to criticize the guy at any
level or is just nothing can be touched
with him I'm not that interested in that
are you you have to decide for yourself
so let's go full circle here the
mainstream media machine is losing
control of the narrative we can very
easily see it on the left when these
people try to attack Elon Musk or Matt
taibi or the nonsense related to the
response to the Nashville shooting but
it's also on the right when it comes to
Trump vaccine Kobe they're just losing
the narrative on everything
and a whole bunch of us are waking up to
it I want to play one more clip uh this
is Tucker going solo last night talking
about how the media has lied for us for
so long and that Trump was the one that
was exposing the lies
for the past seven years that neocon
media establishment's been telling you
that Donald Trump is a dangerous lunatic
in two years in office Joe Biden has
brought the world to the brink of
nuclear Holocaust
who's the dangerous lunatic and they're
lecturing about global warming
so it's interesting he goes on and on to
talk more about that but the point being
that we have been told for a long long
time that Trump was the one who was an
idiot and a buffoon and a racist and a
Nazi and all of these things but things
were way better I mean really guys try
to remember for one second
try to remember for one second five days
before covid the economy was cooking
there was the nonsense in the media
Trump's evil and blah blah blah but like
it was all working covid then demolished
everything and Trump made massive
mistakes during Kobe there's no doubt
about it he backed fauci all the way
through right he was praising Gavin
Newsom virtually all the way through he
did Operation warp speed and he still
defends that which put this experimental
quote-unquote vaccine in the arms of so
many people and was pushing people to
get booster shots just something like
six months ago so he made mistakes all
the way but he clearly was not the guy
that was leading us into World War III
which far more seems like the Democrats
right now because if you say anything
remotely uh isolationist or we shouldn't
just you know spend endless amounts of
money arming Ukraine or just I'm a
little curious about what we're actually
doing there and you know that Putin guy
does have nukes is there's something to
worry about here if you say any of that
they'll tell you that you're a Putin
apologist and you're a Russian stooge
etc etc
so what is the machine supposed to be
doing while it's leading us into World
War III what I think what the media
machine is supposed to be doing is
questioning things right it's given me
it's given me a great Avenue to have a
career right because they seem
completely incapable of doing their job
but there's plenty of other people who
are now
looking at the mainstream media and
going man I wish you just weren't that
terrible and I always say it it's like I
don't even think the mainstream media
has to be particularly good I think they
just have to not be abjectly awful but
they seem un uh incapable of doing that
another guy who's been getting this and
I think has really built an incredible
career off it is Joe Rogan and here he
is going off on mainstream media
it used to be that the media was the
primary place that people would go to
find out what's going on in the world
but now the media conveniently leaves
out anything that it doesn't want to be
at the front and center in in terms of
like things that people concentrate on
and talk about you know all it is is
like January 6th January 6th did you see
what they did January
Trump is coming back but January 6 looms
large how about the fact that the guy
who's the president right now can't form
a sentence he makes up words and
stumbles through things no one says a
goddamn thing about it
yeah so there's Rogan just laying out
the basic truths that I try to lay out
here every day there is a huge
disconnect between what is getting
fed To Us by the mainstream media the
corporate press the Democrat politicians
and then what reality is on the ground
so you know what we need we need new
voices we need new Fighters we need new
platforms we need New Media we need to
knew all of it as I always say and we
can do it you know there was that joke a
couple years ago when a whole bunch of
us were complaining about Twitter we
were complaining about YouTube and
Facebook and censorship there were these
uh sarcastic comments always coming at
me and coming at many people go build
your own internet don't like it they're
private companies go build your own
internet well you know what I did do
that I went ahead and did that and I
created locals.com and we merged with
Rumble and you know it was announced
this morning Rumble will now be the
exclusive video partner the exclusive
live stream video partner of all the
Republican debates that's right they
will not be on YouTube they will all be
on Rumble it was announced this morning
here's just a quick little promo video
because we are going ahead and changing
the game
and so I competition is good in the
marketplace if more people go to
rumble.com Maybe YouTube will someday
say oh my goodness people are leaving us
and nobody's gonna want to participate
maybe they'll change their ways my
official office has adopted Rumble as
our video sharing service of choice
because Rumble stands for freedom of
speech we will expand and the frontiers
of human knowledge and extend the
horizons of human achievement another
opportunity to get away from YouTube and
that is to use rumble.com listen do you
I can't tell you what to do you're
saying stop supporting people Google
owns YouTube that don't support us and
they didn't tell you it was big didn't
tell you it was hacked why'd you take it
down Rumble Kevin McCarthy I'm the
Republican leader of the House of
Representatives so I know what it means
to be on the receiving end of big Tech
bias censorship and Castle culture and I
also know what it's going to take to
fight back for a free and open internet
and Rumble is leading the way
[Music]
information my brothers and
what I want you to do right now is open
up your laptop get out your iPad or your
iPhone or whatever device are you using
and I want you to go over to rumble.com
Ruben report I want you to click that
subscribe button I want you to go to the
highest mountain and yell to everybody
that they've got to subscribe to the
thing you see I became Cosby at the end
of that
we got a cold close for you a little
Gavin do some nonsense and then we got a
post game show for you in just about 32
seconds because we do a post-game show
at the
programs I'm Dave Rubin thank you for
watching God Bless America God bless you
people
see what the hell's going on clean it up
you've heard in bloviate on TV
interviews and social media but never
before have all his failures been
brought together in one collection uh we
all need to self-medicate periodically
the people that brought you Biden's
blunders in kamala's cackles now proudly
present Gavin newsom's Greatest Hits
this whole damn border debate is made up
it's made up and who could forget well
finally California is going to get it
right with this new High-Speed Rail
Timeless Classics if we can just get
everybody vaccinated that's not
vaccinated that's refusing to get
vaccinated this living vaccine free and
impacting the rest of us it's like drunk
drivers and cliches these are organized
gangs of people that are coming out and
forgive me for the same games
Jordan
the organized groups of folks everyone's
favorite deeply sorry
about that I've hurt someone I care
deeply about Alex Turk his friends and
family platitudes I thought I was Dumb
and it looked like a third world country
we haven't been looking that good
in the last few decades in the state and
failures like and that's why we
established this framework what we call
a 10-year plan to end chronic homeless
in San Francisco order Gavin newsom's
greatest hits by calling one
916-445-28416 weeks for delivery money
back guarantee please for the love of
God to keep this guy out of the White
House
[Music]
thank you